story of a very modern period her
publications had focused on the marriage
contract the first focus America change
property in such a low countries
specialization page up late medieval
cities and most recently commerce before
Kathleen Europe that she's also work out
such as roommate resources with
colleagues in Europe all reliable
sources impressively she's working on
the culture of credit in Northern Europe
services
connected she also marked my teachings
now the wider world and questions
and commerce trade in perspective
matalan zealot speaking out especially
with the Chinese
has read the work of Chinese legal and
economic history she's very widely
shareholding this is organization China
statement
great work
collector
attractive property rights very hard
China which is especially welcome
for merchants illegal Despero enterprise
china last basis a third way procharger
bullet is now is this wide-ranging
interest the spurious work on the
patricians shop for his 1972 studies
slamming social history then he's been
working somewhat different and access to
colleagues working on
and you're respectively at Betty's were
cap on the wheel 7775 cop common
capitals of early Islamic grad workers
herders hamburgers has a future human
animal relations then water work on the
case of Islamic Christian civilization
thousand four and then why are still a
global history which teaches stress
instead Bishop of history of the 20th
century and they're more recently is
textbook earth and its peoples trying to
retire or blocking so that's what we
start with me okay so so let me just
start by saying I'm not going to try and
replicate the the thesis of the book
although I have to say you know in some
respects the thesis is fairly simple it
has to do with what i want i won't even
try well i don't know because not not
everybody's read it so you tell me if
i'm wrong i mean you start out by saying
politics is important the key is the key
to your thesis has to do with spatial
divergences that that emerged in europe
and china and that ultimately due to the
cost of war that exists in the
competitive state system in Europe as
opposed to the what I'm going to call a
peace dividend in the Chinese case we
see the urban basis of manufacturing
developing more more substantially in
Europe and a more rural based
manufacturing going on in China that is
sort of the basic but there's so much
more in the book I mean the book is so
thick with with things to talk about
that I had a very hard time thinking
what exactly i would do especially
because I know most of you in the room
probably haven't read the book yet
although I hope because we posted it you
were able to at least reach some of the
chapters and and also I think it's very
clear and I'm sure Ben
running into this that as soon as you
have an overarching thesis like this
even if you very modestly say we are not
trying to have the final word on the
great divergence that they're going to
be a lot of people who attack the
project just for trying to be so broad
and there'll be a lot of people who want
to pick at every you know every load
point in every little fact and so on so
I'm going to try not to do either one of
those I want to start out partly because
I know there are a lot of students here
and a lot of students who don't do
economic history so I want to start out
by saying some of the things that I
really like about this book and and
reasons that you should read it and
reasons why you shouldn't be afraid that
there are equations in it well they're
not really because there's narratives he
had their little boxes and then they're
in room balls right and then there are
narratives that really explain to you
and actually it's like they really do go
a long way in saying these economic
historian to just use equations that the
emperor has no clothes because it really
is a logical way of laying out an
understanding of the world so so first
of all I want to say that in doing so a
lot of Scott a lot of scholars focus on
the impact of institutions both in the
way they'd been defined them and also in
the way that I think people more
generally understands the understand
them as you know is physical things the
impact of institutions on development
and one of the things that I really love
about this book it's something that I I
think a lot of what I do is based on and
and that I urge all of you to keep
really in your minds is this notion that
different institutions can play similar
roles that that when humanity in its
many contexts are faced with similar
problems there are many institutional
solutions
be found in that and that it's not
necessarily the case that there are good
ones and bad ones although there may be
good ones and bad ones but but that
needs to be investigated and I think
that's one of the most important
implications of the book and also of a
lot of the of the models that you that
you draw also like many economic
historians been and shoulder one have
structured their arguments around models
of economic behavior models of our
models are based on assumptions right
there they they're based on assumptions
that economic activity can be simplified
and represented in particular ways and
has been said sometimes people will
disagree about those assumptions I found
that most of their assumptions at least
when I'm looking at the China side made
sense and also that human
decision-making is based on so-called
rational choices this is perhaps more
contentious in looking at the ways in
which these models are designed and and
been talked about the model that I was
going to talk about that is the model
that tries to explain when you have
formal and informal informal enforcement
mechanisms in it credit transactions and
trade relations so I don't have to talk
about that and that saves a little bit
of time modeling can be full of pitfalls
and I think to their credit one of the
other things that I like about the book
is that bin and she only one had me very
judicious use of their models and I want
to speak for historians whose work is
largely empirical that I really enjoyed
and really
ciated the fact that whenever you had a
model you always went back to the stuff
on the ground to try and see how to test
whether it really works in the real
world and and that for that alone I
think you also ought to read the book
because a lot of people don't do that
and then finally been in Jean Laran
depend on this combination of modeling
and empirical testing to debunk some of
the most enduring and irksome ah and I
really mean work some explanations that
are put forward for Chinese economic
development trajectories which which now
i think really do give us something more
than just an intuitive arsenal to attack
people like David Landis and others so
for those of you aren't as deeply
steeped in the literature that as some
of us are they really go into the
question of whether differences in
family structure were at fault whether
the presence or absence of formal legal
institutions work at full specific kinds
of legal regimes there are many many
many many
many books that say that certain kinds
of property rights are necessary for
development in certain kinds i eat
Chinese or not the need for
representative governmental institutions
you spoke evapor but there's a much
broader question about different kinds
of cultural endowments and so on it and
they really do try to deal with each of
them in both the theoretical and an
empirical way and I think you'll find
that very very valuable it's also worth
noting that that Ben and jon renau
writing at a time when it's really no
longer possible to deny that divergence
is actually something that happens at a
moment in time this is sort of something
you said in that wonderful talk that
that you gave on I guess on the ass text
well yeah right but this notion that
somehow we have a priority of West in a
primordial every place else and never
the twain shall meet although we can
disagree about specifics that we can
disagree about when things happen I
think that that the book of benefits
from not having to have that argument
even though I'm going to have that
argument with you in a minute um and I'm
not going to talk about chem Pomerance
because you already did um but I will
say so let me let me skip over my
comrades bin once genre on comments and
say that it seems to me that central to
the books argument as I just said is
that is a claim that trying to
experienced what we might call long-term
peace dividend that was the result both
of its large size and it's centralized
state system and that this peace
dividend allowed for low taxation
and robust provision of public goods in
contrast to the way that you depict
Europe which is saddled with for various
reasons high taxes and low provision of
public goods before the Industrial
Revolution so far ok hi I say so with
nature centers ok no no that's so first
of all I want to say as someone who
whose early work focused a lot on on the
tax system in the early chain that I can
attest to the fact that everything you
say about low taxation and and the
dramatically low burden of Taxation on
on the commercial sector in China and
the lack of barriers to trade and so on
and so forth this is accepted this is
this is not debatable it is exactly the
way that the mainstream in the field
understands that now sparse their
scholars like for example mark elven who
some of you might have read who have
explored the implications of this what
you might call a continental free trade
zone for innovation and investment and
thought about it in a lot of ways in
some ways elvins high level equilibrium
trap depends on this this continental
free trade zone if you will but none of
them have linked low taxation open
markets and state policy in quite the
way that your book does so I want to ask
you some questions and they're not the
only questions and maybe they're not
even the most important questions but
I'll just throw them out first of all a
big part of the argument it seems to me
has to do with the provision of public
goods and so I was wondering how first
of all how do we
measure the chink provision of public
goods one of the things that I have to
say being a Chinese historian is very
frustrating because it's hard to measure
anything no oh but but i think i saw i
want us I want to ask would we have
expect different consequences if a large
portion of this revenue that you say is
devoted to public goods is devoted to
famine relief in flight control as
opposed to say road and bridge building
and indeed i'll leave it there although
i'll just say lillian lee so you know
what i was thinking about because lily
and argues that a lot of this
infrastructure work is actually a net
has negative implications um now a
number of another thing that i was going
to ask you about a number of critics of
the book have have questioned and I I
must say I was thinking about this as
well the characterization of China as
relatively free of military expenses and
not having an end of warfare and of that
having a major impact on the difference
in the way in which the trade system and
the manufacturing system developed and
and I how are so first of all how do you
take into account the late ming and
early qing experience of extremely
costly rebellions wars of dynastic to
transition that go on for those of you
in the european field from from around
1600 to at least the 1680s and then
there followed by costly wars of western
expansion wars against indigenous
populations that don't necessarily
affect the the markets of
eastern China but they certainly
bankrupt the state and indeed we know
and this we do have data for that the
state goes from surplus in the early
18th century to deficit in the late 18th
century okay so that's another question
I'll ask the third question and then
I'll stop because Vicki wants me to um
yeah no I understand ok so the third
question that I was going to ask us to
do with the causes of this of this
spatial divergence and infect you you
default the first chapter sort of to it
and I found that the most difficult
chapter to wrap my head around in fact
it may not be necessary it may not be
possible to explain why China stays
unified or why Europe breaks up but but
the explanation for me is just not there
yet in fact on page 16 you say something
which I can only describe as
tautological you say that the Chinese
rulers were able to reconcile Adid the
vast empire that emerged and I don't
know if this is a quote or not that
emerged in early China because they
learn from their mistakes and we're able
to deliver internal order and Welfare
enhancing projects and the Europeans
were not basically that that somehow
they face competition will the Chinese
space competition also as you know I you
know really after the Han Dynasty Falls
we have assist up we have a state system
which is really rather than fragmented
and doesn't really come back together
until the Middle Ages towards the end of
the book you throw in a comparison
between Machiavellian
fuchsias which I don't think you really
need to be an explanation for it the
differences in the state systems in one
point in the book and I'm saying is
particularly for dick because this is
the kind of thing I think that you would
often get your teeth around you make a
very playful reference to the fact that
the models conquered all of China but
they didn't get quite far enough in
Europe maybe that the reason why China
is unified and Europe ends up not being
my brother stop the talking unless I
find absolutely fascinating because I
look at it from an ottoman standpoint
here you have an empire that is
territorial a spacious next year it has
no words except on the frontiers of
sorts of wars that man is talking about
so that lets say Egypt Syria Oh most of
Anatolia go without war for three to
four centuries and it has unlike Europe
where you have the D urbanization find
the Roman Empire you do not have the
organizations that you have massive
urbanization and so it's a highly
urbanized part of the world it develops
long distance trade early and develops
all of the informal institutions that
can talk about that associate
early development of long distance
training and also develops formal
institutions particularly in the context
of a song about of an illustration so
that these are simply some of the
factors of leaving to think well why are
we talking about Europe and China when
we use those same terms if we talk about
your evidence and its next door neighbor
the Ottoman Empire and yet the audit the
Ottoman Empire never gets drawn into it
because you did not have no one's ever
been able to arrange and they can't back
it up that you have a kind of potential
for for industrialization in terms of
gross measures of oh how could coal
things like that but it is interesting
that among the most dynamic economies in
the world today of Turkey which is
illness core so being a old fashioned on
at least and technological historian I
look for other factors that strike me as
being germain not so much of why they're
there was a vergence of the sort of
enjoy about but simply why these two
neighboring areas that are both heirs of
greco-roman antiquity and the
Hellenistic toolkit of ideas and
scientific concepts and so forth why
these two in virgin I agree entirely
with with the speaker in terms of my
rejection of cultural differences I
think that that has
then the Shibboleth in the field of
between studies and I also think that
the whole notion of comparison suffers
from the fact that that the field of
Middle Eastern history has been pretty
much brain dead for glass several
generations in that virtually no one
asks crucial questions and therefore we
don't have the sort of conceptual face
so it allow us to make that comparison
there's recently book trying to draw
India into this a great diverted to
think part of our surroundings look but
nobody works on Middle East because
nobody does that kind of history now
that's a follower feel about a fall
growth of either the source materials or
of the interest ahead so I just like to
make three points that I think are
participating what is but I think we
have a very important issue in the cost
of energy the cost of energy in in
Europe is associated with trying to to
harness water power wind power through
water middleton windmills which has a
very high investment cost but has a very
good long-term product and many of the
people who were most important my
understanding was in the development of
European industry were people who a
generation to the back have backgrounds
in the military business because they
are also knew how to how to transmit
energy from a
say from a watermill to a group of looms
or saw mill operation or something like
that they have the technical skills they
knew how to do that but the water mills
the mills that you have here are not
there before before the 12th century you
have a massive increase in mills in the
11th and 12th 13th centuries and that is
something that does not occur in the
middle east part of the reason is it is
I believe because there's a period of a
great population growth in Europe where
with the question of the cost of animal
power which is your primary alternative
is goes up because humans and adults
compete for the same feed grains the
important thing in my view is that
throughout the herbs of arid zone down
in the present day the the feeding cost
of laboring animals is approximately
zero we actually have good economic
studies that demonstrate this there's a
study in Pakistan done in 1985 showing
that for some of renting out a candle
for labor it's a wonderful budget that
says 200 you know 260 working days per
year cost of food 0 of 100 leisure days
per year cost of food 0 you know if your
energy costs is that low you will not
invest in water bottles or finials even
if you have the technology which they
could have abilities so that you have
something of the same level we have now
pour gasoline
prices are too low or often we're too
low to encourage investment in
alternative forms so that's that's first
point the second point is that there was
a massive change in the balance of
economic capacity between Europe
abilities that set in primarily in the
11th 12th 13th centuries 11th 12th
centuries our periods of great
exuberance in Europe supported largely
by what's called a Medieval Warm Period
great warming of the arcane climate just
coincides Middle East the period of
extraordinary cold so that could have a
the opposite climate effect you have
depopulation loss of agricultural
production and all sorts of terribly
deleterious effects because of a cold
period that runs from roughly mid 900s
down to say 1130 or so I've written
about this in my book on cotton fiber
camels early Islamic Iran or recently
ironic ellenburg people universities or
an entire look on the decline of of
eastern Mediterranean in the 11th
century and I think it's going to become
understood that the shift in the balance
between Europe the Islamic Middle East
had an exogenous cost or certain
exemptions causes just one word in the
Miller business but let me just go back
to if you track European history behind
that the two most important traits in
terms of surnames are Miller and spent
the people worked with firing people
work with water or web and you look at
American surnames of whether it's
ferrara 11 re or whether the Schmidt and
Mueller whether it's Miller & Smith
these are two important look at the
American surnames 44 Arabic most common
surname for Araxes had that he's death
there are no Miller's Bob because Billy
was a single animal operation that never
rose to industrial level because you
didn't have any way of multiplying you
have no no energy take off to be used to
turn the middle into a factory final
point the comments on time and distance
with respect to transactions simply
inevitably raise the question of speed
and efficiency of web transport and
because your your kilometer is where
your weeks so forth have to be
conditioned by how fast you you can move
fundamental fact of European history is
that contrary to to economic efficiency
or good sense of the Europeans for
hundreds of years retain the use of four
wheeled vehicles that are intrinsically
inferior to with to build vehicles China
everywhere else in the world China India
Japan everywhere else will relieve was
to build vehicles but modern transport
is predicated on the concept of a
four-wheeled platform carrying imagine
all of the development that you have
from the carriage revolution of roughly
1,600 onward in terms of improving roads
brakes steering etc etc becomes the
the template builds the template upon
which modern motor trans work
particularly railroad experiment is
built and no other part of the world was
stupid enough to do to use four wheeled
transport and therefore they never
developed that that interest that cost
and therefore they never develop never
develop the infrastructure why the
Europeans did this is a topic of my next
book very briefly I don't want to
intrude in your time when you look at
pictures of four wheeled vehicles
outside the narrow road stratum they're
almost all passenger vehicles and you do
not see them being used to carry cargo
because as soon as you add the second
axle you double the friction thereby
decreasing your payload and therefore
they make no sense to cargo killing
four-wheel vehicle but when you look at
the passenger vehicles as you move into
the medieval period of the rise of
vipers no man that status could rise a
vehicle reed akley channel 12
my lovely of the car a man would be
disgraced by writing in the vehicle
unless he was holding firm and almost
all pictures are of these vehicles are
women particularly high status women
being moved with a residue of female
containers and four-wheel vehicle be
inefficient for inefficiency of four
wheeled vehicles was the price Europe
paid to move its women whereas other
parts of the world two-wheeled vehicles
simply did not move the women they left
them at all because the cost of moving
princess and her retinue from here to
there well it was an artist the
exception forces Marco Central Asia but
women sensibly roe versus but but it's
one of these curious things where it's
the gender history of Europe that that
plays a role in the retention and indeed
and the improvement to have a smoother
ride smoother road map of a field
transport so Europe ended up
unconsciously and because and for
reasons that nothing to his economics
with a step toward toward narrowing the
time and space factor in transactions
that no other part of the world was
prepared to to do in
let me begin there's everybody else
began by thanking our presenter I found
this presentation enormously clarifying
i had read chapters of the book and in
fact what i'm going to talk about for
part of my remarks are chapter 4 which
is the chapter on warfare which is
really sort of the heart of the causal
argument of this book as maddie pointed
out so but i did find a presentation
that explained more the methodology just
exactly what they were trying to do
methodologically very useful and helpful
but i'm speaking as a specialist to the
socio economic history of late medieval
europe into the sixteenth and
seventeenth century and some of what i
have to say is you know inside baseball
a little the specialists quibble what
I'm not going to do is quibble too much
and stay with the really tiny things I
wanted to say just parenthetically the
argument about informal and formal
mechanisms first of all I think it's
empirically right that European
historians are agreed that informal
mechanisms were key part of the credit
system whether the kind of two you know
the two by two table or the three by
three table perfectly captures the
complexity I'm not
but certainly the mix that you described
i agree with but let me turn just first
I have that Mike Linville question which
I think leads to a bigger issue and then
I have some comments at the end about
method about the risks and rewards of
this kind of method with respect to the
story in Europe and of course i'm going
to talk just about Europe because I
don't know anything about China and I
presume that's why I was asked that
central argument is is that early in
Europe's history medieval history cities
developed as havens as sort of refuges
against from a warlike exterior and when
Europe industrialized and industrialized
in cities because cities were safer and
because capital was cheaper in cities
the cities may have been safer on
average than the countryside although I
don't really know how you measure the
cost of the higher mortality and cities
because of z's which book acknowledges
against the cost of warfare particularly
because periods of warfare
very uneven and exactly the period of
European dramatic urbanization which
professor bullet just referred to is the
period from 1100 to 1300 the great
warming of Europe which was the peaceful
period in European history so cities
developed during a peaceful time in
Europe's history the early modern period
when the real excitement happens about
pre industrialization is in fact a
terribly bloody period in your village
the most bloody medieval gets a very bad
rap about its violence and more fair
it's a sixteenth and seventeenth century
there with it centuries in terms of
summer rotting soldiers destruction of
city this is the period of the sack of
Antwerp of Ghent among the cities in the
south so but maybe that European cities
were safer but I don't know quite how
that fits with the argument that they're
making except with possibly with regard
to capital costs and labor costs they
were all swerve I are in cities and I
have a remark about that that I want to
make it
and capital costs may have been cheaper
in cities I mean they were in Europe
capital was easier to obtain the
institutions to protect your investment
your loans were more robust in cities
etc but that's in a way circular
argument that's where the Commerce was
that's where the merchants were so
that's where the systems existed for for
raising capital the way most European
historians understand this this social
topography of Europe in which cities are
indeed walled with turrets and watches
and soldiers and all those sorts of
things as though defending themselves
from the countryside and they are in
fact defensive most of them is that they
were different kinds of political
entities they were intrusions on a
landscape with a different
jurisdictional authority different long
different customs and a different
economy and so the argument honor would
make about why industry by that he been
mean and I leave in this context
commercialized industry winds up being
located in cities is because it's the
way the citizens ie people who have
rights as citizens in the city as
opposed to being subject to a lord in
the countryside is it that that's how
they protect property rights that's how
they keep a claim on their property so
these cities which were in fact
defensive were also jurisdictional
spaces subject to different laws they
were and here vapours still make some
sense they were markets
they were the places where markets were
centralized in Europe and they even this
is the period where something that the
English continued to Paul law merchant
developed and on the continent where
that term doesn't really exist there
were nevertheless a specific set of
commercial laws that developed to
adjudicate contract disputes to decide
about whose property was whose etcetera
that did not obtain in origin in the
city in the countryside because
different system and different kinds of
lawmakers prevailed so I would say that
cities were not refuges for more fair in
fact they were no they were always for
Attica Lee at war with these people in
the countryside they were regularly
doing business with them they were
supplying them arms they were supplying
with luxuries they were supplied in the
trinkets that book constituted and
consolidated their power as a military
leaf in the in the period so in the
industry that was located in cities and
this brings me to the labor issue was a
luxury industry in origin the Commerce
in cities was commerce both in luxury
goods were made in the cities but also
an important luxury goods goods that
came from
x asia from far away or from other parts
of Europe and the industry that built
these famous cities that you know we we
think of as the motors of european
economic development in the late
medieval and early modern period we're
in fact producing highly specialized
goods with a highly specialized closely
controlled labor force and they were
using imported materials to do it cloth
industries in the part of the world i
work in the cloth industries were huge
that that bull came from specific places
in europe through a very sophisticated
merchant network that had access to that
wall the dyes that they used which
constituted up to fifty percent of the
cost of the finished piece of cloth came
from a lot of them came from abroad then
metal industries which is the other
great thing depended on mines in the
most Valley Moravian Bohemia etc and so
that too was in the hands of a merchant
network that got that stuff to the
cities so we're not talking about
remember we're talking about a highly
skilled specific labor force that was in
cities and the task of controlling that
labor force training preserving the
property rights of the citizens in the
city was the job of the cities as
opposed to
the countryside now this you know in
theory all this kind of production the
racing of capital the importing of the
luxury raw materials the jewels from
India to decorate all those things you
see of museums that were made in your
bathroom places like that that could
have been done in the countryside under
a different kind of political system it
wasn't in Europe apparently it was in
China but it wasn't in Europe I think
for the reason that the sort of gross
reason that I've outlined is that this
was under the control of what they
called the bourgeoisie and they didn't
already mean the Marxist bourgeoisie
they meant the urban citizen so I think
that that I would kind of revise my
sense of why cities in Europe and this
peculiar of social de bago fee of Europe
and I would place it in this political
history of what is loosely called
feudalism in Europe now the fact that
commerce was centralized in cities in
luxury industries were centralized in
cities does not mean that the
countryside did not commercialize and in
fact the commercialization of the
countryside in Europe is a hue is a big
part of the story of the
industrialization of Europe even in the
dark ages there were markets in the
countryside
market exchange of some limited kind but
the big story is of course the
agricultural revolution of the sixteenth
and seventeenth century in Europe when
what had been a system that was
organized for subsistence production
with the peripheral connection to the
market gets turned into a system that is
producing for the market and of course
England is the great story where that
happens most clearly but it happens in
many places in Europe as well what that
does is two things number one it
produces a landless class of summer
peasants people that lose their land
there's a whole social history written
about the landless men of early modern
Europe and their revolutionary potential
but also their availability for cheap
wage labor the other part of the story
of what is crudely thought of as
producing a working class for the
eventual Industrial Revolution which
does and on unskilled low-wage labor is
the parcel ization of land in what's
left of the peasant community and
northern France and Belgium work and
then some areas around Switzerland and
in the Rhineland are places where this
increasing parcel ization too many
people survived the land gets divided up
the people you don't have enough land to
support yourself as a peasant you take
in wage work of various kinds industry
spreads to the countryside you get this
famous thing called throw to the proto
industrialization and this becomes in a
complicated way the cheap labor that's
available for the story of urban is it
for industrialization so that's my
quibble that turned into maybe
point I'm going to close with just two
general points I wondered as I read two
of these chapters and a pricey of the
book and then listen tonight with great
interest I never heard the word
capitalism I heard growth market FF
fluorescence industrialization etc now
I'm not going to try to I already tried
to resurrect one of the piece of vapor
I'm not going to try to resident
visceral old Marxist story which has run
its course but I do want to ask why
we're not going to think of that class
we're not going to think about the fact
that even numbers will agree or people
that were never intrigued by a Marxist
narrative will agree that your produced
in the early modern period a class of
entrepreneurs who were rewarded for
taking risks in the marketplace punished
for failure in the marketplace and in
fact compelled in a certain sense to
compete for profits most historians
understand that is a social phenomena
that is if not particular to Europe not
North not unique then a particular kind
of social formation that did if this is
not a relevant part of the story of
Europe's industrialization which for 5th
century historians have argued that it
was why is it not why do we not need to
think about that from when it's not that
I'm talking about the celebration of the
bourgeoisie or something I'm thinking of
that class the fact that we have a labor
force that's produced to occupy a
certain class like position that we have
an entrepreneurial class that emerges
now this leads me um so one of my
husband's is if we're not going to talk
about capitalism why not there has to be
a reason not to the other last thing I
want to say is I want to come to culture
and I was terrified when you were
talking and I thought oh dear I have to
think of another word I couldn't think
of one so I'm going to come back to the
culture now avatar industrialization is
the application of technology to
production right and we already have
from dick buller some explanation of the
European exceptionalism at least with
respect to the Ottoman world now our
authors have a very elegant beautiful
explanation that labor costs were high
in Europe and so it made sense to apply
machines and replace labor
does a nice job of addressing this sort
of perennial problem that here we have
China this technologically advanced
certainly in 1400 and 1500 compared to
Europe that didn't do that I mean one of
the things that's in all the textbooks
that seller in high schools the Chinese
invented fireworks but they never you
know blew up the world with them so so
if that does that the Europeans and
economic incentive to and find
technological solutions to production
because of high labor costs I think then
if that is true and may be true I think
we need a fuller story that is really
culture a cultural story about how
europeans learned to apply technology
how the technological knowledge
circulated why why and this is the
hardest question of all why it seemed
like a good idea
for a miller the guy that knew how to
run the windmill or the water mill that
dick bullet was talking about yes he may
have said oh dear mind you know my
donkey is too slow and eats all my food
and so I'm not going to use my donkey to
ride to make the watermill turn why and
how did that man decide that there was a
another system right how did he learn
and so this it seems to me brings us
back to the question of class not just
class in the sense of a group of people
whose status socially and politically
dependent upon their ability to amass
finance and productive capital but also
a class of people who had access to the
kind of technological training the
technological tools that could be put to
work and there's there's good work now
being done in Europe Maxine Berg has a
new book about the sort of inventors and
England Fiddler's and it seems to me
that that kind of history has to be
included in the history that were trying
to compare I have no idea whether this
did or didn't go on in China
so
well I want to thank all three
discussants for the comments they cover
a large range of issues and I'm I will
seek to in some sense organize the
response in terms of the book has I
should make clear it makes a series of
arguments that look at specific problems
like household structure demography the
way it's been argued in the reasons we
think it's a false set of arguments
similarly in the chapter I talked about
about market development both credit and
transactions commercial transactions the
way people have stylized differences of
formal informal and how we go about
taking that apart and that's one of the
styles of argument a basic element in
the art of the book it seems to me let
me start with Professor halls comments
and say that they they're important and
they affirm a line of inquiry which is
what one expects in history profession
about essentially where are the things
that I know that we study to explain
what happened in Europe why aren't they
part of your story and what does it mean
that they're not there so I want to try
to explain what why they're not there
and there are different reasons and why
what the significance of this is firstly
starting with the issue of cities and
what why do we say cities are a place to
which entrepreneurs go because of the
threat of warfare it's very specifically
to protect their capital to protect it
in other words in so far as being behind
walls is safer than being in the country
sigh or that's what's projected at least
that it you would prefer to be behind
city walls to protect your capital that
says nothing about all the reasons walls
are built or all the reasons urban
growth takes place it makes no claims
about there not being other factors that
explain why cities develop either in
Europe or for that matter in other parts
of the world so it's crucial is that we
were just making a specific claim about
why people would want to move into
cities because of warfare and what the
consequences of that action might be for
the kinds of economic activity takes
place and it proceeds on the assumption
that they're going to be certain types
of activities and textiles to some
extent would be an example of this I
mean it seemed I mean it's a great
disadvantage to all of us that Jon
Ronson here because he would be able to
talk more about the low countries in the
world textiles then I'm dredging up what
I had to read for my oral exams for
david early which was thirty sign it's a
hell of a long time ago I don't it's not
very safe from kind of that kind of
knowledge
and that's why one works with colleagues
so you don't have to keep up with these
literatures but anyway the point is that
the argument proceeds on the assumption
if genre i hear i hope you present
examples of why we think the argument
obtains in europe as well that for
certain types of textiles the equivalent
kind of activity and it's hard because
chinese are doing more copy well again
europeans you use more wool and those
are different technologies that etc but
the point is that that they're in urban
places in Europe where they would be in
the country setting child now the
question if you're going to compare is
you need commensurate kinds of
information to compare how things work
so that difference is between those two
cases help you explain other differences
so methodologically describing what goes
on in one place rather than the other
can't really motor you towards that kind
of explanation the kinds of explanations
that where we typically do in terms of
accounting for what we empirically
observe in a given world region in this
case europe does tell us people are in
cities well the economic reason they're
in cities wasn't the liner suggesting
can be reduced to the issue of security
of capital it really doesn't address how
the city's structured all the features
you talk about are the context within
which their own cities but and if we
find what Chinese cities are not like
that I mean this is in the sense of a
variant the argument the causal
significance of those differences in
economic terms is actually difficult to
evaluate by which I mean the fact that
this is an example of differences exist
everywhere but how do we evaluate what's
the cause of mechanism that we assign to
that difference for other types of
economic effects I mean we do it all the
time but it seems
it's very hard to adjudicate the
relative significance of all manner of
difference in this particular case of
cities as sites of production it just
seems to us to buy the 16th century
there is a difference in craft
industries frequency with whips in the
countryside versus cities and that to us
seems a key element in that has to do
with the threat of warfare in a in a
given space this comes right back to
Maddy's second or third point I no
longer which model is it's actually
number two it's an exasperated point to
me because she mentioned two things
costs and she also talked about the
scale of the military the Arlington we
said in fact we have a paragraph that
reminds people of all the bloody
military campaigns the Jing undertook
the argument is not about the fact that
chain was not a massive military machine
the argument has to do with what on
average millions of people in a lot of
big chunk of China not all of it but a
big space didn't worry about troops
marching through yes there was a main
chain transition and there was Civil War
in the Civil War had major pockets so
there was disruption over literally 80
years well that 80 years is a little
different than the scale of threat of
warfare it seems to me whether we start
the 30 years world where we where we
march it through it seems that it's it's
more it is a larger scale and greater
duration in terms of threat in Europe
than it is in China so in a sense our
argument is is a contrast it's a
relative statement it's not an absolute
statement and it's to isolate the fact
that on average the people who are going
to be engaging economic activities for
producing goods are not going to run
behind city walls in the mansion period
because of the threat of war the threat
of war was typically on peripheries or
frontiers and when it was more general
than that it was a more limited duration
than Europe so it's a relative argument
it's not an absolute the China didn't
have a military ball it's a relic
argument in two senses where it's found
and and when it's fun and so I think you
know and I first certainly it is also
debatable the extent to which this
variable is that important but it is
something you can directly contrast
between the two cases and say there's a
difference in this and we think is
associated with another kind of
difference that's a causal mechanism so
many of these other things are instances
of well Europeans have this and
therefore they have other things well
for that how do we work through the
mechanism like that so here's an example
of and this is the challenge when we're
of getting symmetric kinds of
information first I mentioned Maxine's
Maxine Berg's work in the issue of
invention there's been a lot of work in
the last 15 years on Europeans
development of useful and reliable
knowledge that's the politically correct
way to talk about science and technology
in the early modern period and that's it
that's it and I think that's a youth bet
it's a good way to think of it and so
they asked what kinds of useful reliable
knowledge are is there another in other
parts of the world and the fact that we
know a lot about English and European
invention in general it doesn't tell us
anything about what to it you know what
goes on in China the typical the
standard way this is going to say well
Chinese didn't have that and therefore
they couldn't have something else and
until we know what they were doing it's
hard to know the significance of the
existence of evidence for which we have
no comparable data on the other
I mean that's in terms of technology
that really is the situation we're in
and that we feel there's an implicit and
large danger and inferring from the
absence of European practices in China
than the other things don't happen the
way we know that is in econ in lots of
economic history we were taught 30 years
ago that the Chinese didn't do things
the way the English and Doug North still
trying to teach us that Douglas North
that Nobel laureate the people for whom
institutions are a very specific set of
institutions and that's a very powerful
set of claims even today in development
economics and you know they're all kinds
of distinguished economists are telling
us these things and yet as maddie was
mentioning the fact that you could have
different institutional mixes is one
thing that historians have brought to
the table and the fact is for some of
these things in China we don't yet know
how knowledge circulated so it's very
hard to say how to measure the
significance of the ways knowledge
circulated in New York and for healthy
circulation because the levels of the
scholarship as far as I can tell are
quite uneven if we take and this is one
of the pieces i circulated for this
group i think was a piece I wrote on
Deidre my close-up first of all I'm so
for now projected six following
treatment of bourgeois values virtues
dignity etc and you know the exasperate
about one of the many exasperate things
about that book is the rich detail she
can give us on Dutch and English culture
using literary text legal text
architecture you know good or I don't
know
leave it to cultural stories that are
all good it is but I mean using the kind
of evidence and to my mind a synthesis
of gift of the argument what would want
in that field plus what she comes
forward with is the residue for Chicago
economics training but the you the point
is so they have all that how do I know
what to compare that we with China well
then these fascinating things happen
where she says well you know at a
certain point in time the Chinese get
bourgeois virtues to when I say okay
well why and it turns out well you know
there's no real explanation we just told
they got those values and you sort of
say was it in the air did someone they
really learn how to appreciate Rembrandt
I mean what did they do to become to
have those vows and it's not really
explained in my opinion and when we
correspondent on this she just said I
was a bit what she chose a gentle
adjective but can she called me crabby
or something you're a bit crabby and I
thought no I'm more than crabby I don't
think what you're doing makes sense and
I think that's a problem with cultural
arguments that aren't anchored in
commensurate efforts at evaluations so I
I think that's one of the challenges we
face in responding to thick descriptions
analytically focused on one part of the
world in this case Europe and not
knowing how to you know judge equivalent
things in in the Chinese case I've
already mentioned something about the
military issues it's not a question of
expenditures in a sense that the Chinese
and spent a lot of the military they did
what we try to argue in the book is but
note on margin not all of it went to the
middle
I mean almost almost all public funds
state making estate funds went to
military at certain points in early
modern European history and we know how
important that the failure to keep up
with that was to the security of
polities and the ways in which the
institution they could deal with that
and a lot of and so that's very
important politically but the issue of
how it's important economically is I
would say a different issue so I would
move from the military issue to the
issues you raised about public goods
provisions I think when you say that's a
crucial part of the argument I think it
is one of the arguments we make I don't
think though the Warren manufacturing
argument doesn't depend the public was
argument the public good I mean these
are somewhat separate organs I mean we
would argue we're trying to address
different issues and exemplifying
approach and the approach does come up
with the uncomfortable proposition
uncomfortable to the conventional wisdom
that the Chinese on average provided
better couple more public goods of a
economically productive nature or useful
to the economy than did europeans and a
particular this has to do with the fact
that we as a china field still don't
adequately deal with with the
significance of water control it seems
to me because we know it's important
institutionally we know we don't believe
in a controlling and hydraulic society
and our autocracy and yet we haven't
really sorted through and assemble the
kind of data that the laws is to say
look how much the chinese spent and
let's start making estimates about what
they gained from that in terms of the
product we know paddy agriculture is
much more productive per unit area area
and we know that the the maintenance of
marine waterways is fundamental to the
the transport that allowed the expansion
in that commercial economy but as far as
I can cope we haven't done much effort
have done a good job at all of actually
estimating these kinds of
infrastructural costs the role of the
government in making those possible and
we missed them in part auto just do this
as quick as I can in the 18th century
officials often to repair irrigation
works there was nothing in their budgets
to allow this and they deliberately
borrowed from one budgetary item did the
work then they this a temporary surtax
on the land and replaced it into the
original budget item it never turns up
in a budget so if you're doing the
reconstruction of budgets and what the
Chinese are doing you'll never see it if
someone's impeached well that's done
look exactly unless unless somebody had
the misfortune to borrow the money and
not get it back in the account before
someone came and said hey screwed up but
the point is it was structured so that
officials were very vulnerable and I
can't I don't have time to explain all
the week and that's a whole set of
issues about how the bureau arcs works
but in terms of the public finance
feature of it it means that one of the
basic things Chinese did in the 18th
century to maintain where the government
spent money and then raised money for
water control we cannot pick up very
systematically and most people have
looked at this haven't even bothered and
recognize that this is actually a
pervasive phenomena so it's that kind of
problem that makes the argument rows of
the line makeup up hella fine it's
difficult to impurity you know to
produce the kind of happy happy meaning
solid figures I mean when John brewer
about the city's the power and talked
about this vast increase in the fiscal
size of the 18th century English state
he could do so because the expansion of
the state was predicated on the bringing
and all these excise customs all isn't
it get got great records that
kind of physical things that the Chinese
did they had ideological reasons for
claiming minimal government and when
they even did things they like to find
ways of until the second half 19th
century for not even telling us how they
did it I mean they that was part of the
way they they did things crudely put
that doesn't make it easy for us to make
commensurate comparisons but in any
event the chapter we have in that was at
least a provisional effort to point us
towards in our end there I should also
say that we were consciously thinking
the way economists think about the
problem of public goods and there is
this important theory in public finance
that imagines the democracies do a
better job of provisioning in public
goods than non democracies and and their
reasons theoretical reasons that's an
important argument and we wanted to find
a way to qualify that so we could
demonstrate that the limits of that as
an explanation so that had a very
specific kind of method theoretical
motivation behind it that again that
issue is very distinct from the market
institutions issue which is in turn
distinct from the warfare manufacturing
all of them are united by I think a
common methodological approach to how we
evaluate these things professor bullets
the comments were fascinating and as I
interpreted them largely not related to
what we were doing
and darfur